hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
pneumonia
diagnosis bacterial super infection and
covid19 patients
i'm alexis krauss of labberts and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by opgen a precision
medicine company harnessing the power of
molecular diagnostics
and bioinformatics to help combat
life-threatening infectious diseases
and fight antimicrobial resistance to
improve patient care
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their website
at opgen.com so let's get started
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
dr christian jeske professor had a
division of clinical microbiology
and immunology department of laboratory
medicine
karolinska institute at stockholm sweden
and dr drew bell medical and public
health microbiology fellow
indiana university school of medicine
department of pathology and laboratory
medicine
in indianapolis indiana for a complete
biography on our presenters
please visit the biography tab at the
right side of your screen
dr jeske you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir
so thank you very much for the
introduction the title of my talk is
diagnosing bacterial pneumonia
in covid 19.
the scope of today's presentation is to
give you an overview of state-of-the-art
diagnosis of bacterial pneumonia and
also to describe complexities and
challenges of pneumonia
diagnosis in co-igniting patients
i would also like to discuss with you
potential clinical consequences of lack
of diagnostics
and to give you some examples from a
study at karolinska on code 19 patients
with hospital acquired pneumonia
comparing diagnostic outcomes with
univero
lrt panel and quantitative cultures
finally i would like to give you some
examples of clinical utility in selected
patients
according to medical chart review
uh following the second you have um
established uh that you um assume
the clinical syndrome to be pneumonia
the second part
of making a diagnosis is selection
selecting the correct sample material
and in the following slides we will
discuss that
um and discuss what the options
are for uh lower respiratory tract
sampling one sampling
type which is very accessible um
is the sputum sample the problem of this
sample is that it's always contaminated
with the oral microbiome
it's also very clear that qualitative
cultures have limited diagnostic value
and it's absolutely necessary to assess
the specimen quality
which should be low in epithelial cells
and high in neutrophils
also noteworthy in many patients
it's helpful to do nebulized
sodium chlorides to induce
coughing and that can also be done with
the assistance of a physical therapist
if you conduct sputum wash you can
remove a large part
of the oral microbiome but that's
usually not a standard practice
everywhere if you have good quality
sputum
and growth of a significant amount which
is defined as
more than 10 to 5 cpu per ml
the sensitivity has in various
investigations been found to be around
60 to 80
and specificity around 90 so it can be a
fairly good
test but noteworthy uh
for instance for the clinical syndrome
we are discussing with covid19
many of these patients are unable to
produce sputum
even when they are exposed to
um induction
this leads us to a need for invasive
sampling in these patients usually
to get the lower respiratory tract
sample and one of the key
tools we have there is the protected
specimen brush or
psb which is a brush which is millimeter
sized
on the edge of a metal wire protected by
a plastic catheter
and sealed by a plug and following the
sampling the catheter is cut off and the
brush is
sent in one milliliter nutrient broth
uh it is a test with a good sensitivity
and specificity according to
a meta-analysis uh what can also be said
um about the the brush
is that it can be taken either through
bronchoscope but also
through a tube in ventilated patients
which is not as good since you cannot
see exactly where you are in the
respiratory tract but it still
is a very helpful test where you can get
the sample
more efficiently also in a patient who
is
ventilated we also have
an option of doing uh different forms of
lavage
the classical bronchio alveolar or bal
sample is done with 100 to 150
sodium chlorides which is injected and
then you
conduct desperation of around 100 mls
and this is also common in icus to do
so-called
low volume bal which is done
with around one-tenth of the volume
and also with the much lower yields
uh the overall performance is the
sensitivity of
73 and specificity of 82
with a cut-off of 10 to 4 cfu per ml
according to um most of these references
are from almost 20 years back but they
are quite
good robust
investigations one final
sample which can also be taken
invasively is the
endotracheal aspirate or eta
which has a low specificity if it's only
done a
qualitative manner but if it's done
quantitatively it's it's a fairly good
test
standardization is is a key challenge
with this sample type since
frequently people will use it in many
different forms
and it has very good performance both in
terms of sensitivity and specificity
compared
to other samples like
for instance psp if you use a cutoff of
10 to the 5c view per ml
in summary uh if you do quantitative
cultures
these are the interpretation criteria
that would be
um would be evident from several
different investigations and are i would
say to a large extent
internationally well accepted cut-offs
where you have for bal
um and low volume bal
somewhere around 10 to 3 to 10 to 4
for psp it's 10 to 3 and eta and sputum
10 to 5 and 6
and you can also have a cutoff for
possible significance if you want
a buffer category to ensure that you are
not
dismissing too many findings
in terms of the general guidelines these
are some examples
of the swedish guidelines for sampling
in low respiratory tract there is quite
some interest in doing lower respiratory
tract sampling in sweden perhaps more so
than
at least in some other european neighbor
countries
and in hospital acquired pneumonia
excluding that it and
in that it's quite common to look at
the same set of samples so lower
respiratory culture is always
recommended along with blood culture
and urinary antigen and then to varying
degrees
uh looking for also atypical pathogens
and and even non-tuberculous
mycobacteria and nocardia
are more common obviously to look for in
immunosuppressed patients
and then viruses well those are looked
for in
all samples these days but prior to
kovids it was common
um not to routinely look for it in in
hap and that
and honestly all of the patients we are
talking about here
already are diagnosed with covid so it's
also not necessary to
to conduct pcr for covid if they develop
a hat which they usually do after
some initial time in hospital so some of
the limitations of the quantifications
is that for some bacteria it's
not really considered relevant to
consider it that you have
some kind of colonization or safe
level another important aspect is that
treatment before sampling can affect the
quantification and can obviously also
lead to false negative results
sampling early in the course of
infection can give you results below the
cut off
and there is also problems of
reproducibility
in many investigations this has been
shown that it can differ with one
dilution step when taking multiple
samples with the same technique
and even the concentration can vary with
different
sampling sites in one log long segment
and that lack of reproducibility is a
bit
inflated even when you look at um
samples that are taken to to the tube
in ventilated patients
you one can also question if it's
important to conduct invasive sampling
and there is limited support in one
cocktrain analysis that sampling is
improving
mortality but there is definitely
support that sampling
is decreasing the overall antimicrobial
exposure
and in in fact for the the covid
patients
invasive sampling is in many ways the
only way
of getting good samples from the lower
respiratory tract
i would also say that many of the old
studies showing that
sampling is not improving mortality are
also done
in times with lower frequency of amr
and might want to be repeated so when
you do cochrane analysis with old
studies
that cannot sometimes be a caveat
obviously sampling should not delay
therapy and
um but if it has been done according to
standards it can definitely guide
decisions on therapy
and um there are different practices in
different countries with some
that are more positive to conduct
invasive sampling
to promote good and microbial
stewardship
and importantly lack of sampling leads
to lack of data
to modify guidelines over time
i can add that at karolinska initially
there was
some um uncertainty with icu physicians
uh who feared that there would be a
great risk
of transmitting covid if they did
sampling so initially they were a bit
careful
but quite early on we were able to
convince that this was still very
important that we got these samples
when patients developed hospital
acquired pneumonia
so in discussion further about the
ethiology of hospital-acquired pneumonia
it's quite clear first of all that
there are some findings which
are sometimes reported in studies but uh
should uh at least in my opinion be uh
be questioned
those are uh for instance enterococci
quaglace negative staphylococci and also
candida species
there is also a couple of bacteria that
are
largely considered to belong to the
respiratory microbiota such as the
streptococcus metis group
of which pneumococcus is also one of the
members
streptococcus pseudopneumonia um is
uh one of the um uh the it's been
discussed sometimes as a pathogen but
it's still uncertain haemophilus para
influency
there is some some um
not always agreement on whether that
should be considered or not
and there are even some other crime
bacteria like pseudo destruction
which is sometimes considered a pathogen
at least
in immunosuppressed patients but
sometimes
also as respiratory microbiota
i would like like to raise a word of
caution
for some studies that finding
a microbe in a patient with a clinical
syndrome
does not necessarily mean that this is
a causative pathogen of that syndrome
and in fact many
covet patients presented early on with
a clinic clinical picture resembling
community acquired bacterial pneumonia
but there were no findings of bacteria
in their lungs at that stage and it just
tells you that
although the picture looks like
bacterial pneumonia and you find
something which i described to be a
potential colonizer
that doesn't make that bug the causative
pathogen
and this is just a reminder about cox
postulates where
there is actually also a part where you
should
uh try the microorganism in an animal
model to see that it actually causes
that
kind of clinical picture to give you an
idea of the
uh panorama of disease uh in sweden
where
the study i'm going to be describing
later was conducted
this is some um
insight into the axiology of ventilator
associated pneumonia
in south sweden and at karolinska and we
see more or less
the expected pathogens
with staph aureus being quite common
hemophilus influenzae
and also to varying degrees we can see
different
gram negatives and sometimes a bit more
rare findings as well in different
international literature uh this is uh
um a review uh um a french
review of of several papers
that have and health
healthcare-associated pneumonia
and we can see that overall um
anthrobacterialis or entrovectory ac
as it was called then is around
one-third
non-fermenters around one-third and
gram-positive cockguy
around one-third that is the
the overall picture when when looking at
these
studies there is also quite limited
differences between
healthcare-associated pneumonia health
hospital acquired pneumonia and
ventilator associated pneumonia
normally we have most diagnostics for
ventilator associated pneumonia so
that's where we have most of the
ideologies from
since those patients are more likely to
be sampled
invasively than than many other
categories of patients
another important factor to consider is
al also um the um risk factor for
resistant pathogens
and for this particular
situation uh prior intravenous
antibiotic use
is a big risk factor for mdr
ventilator associated pneumonia there
are also other things
like septic shock at the time of the ap
ards and five or more days of
hospitalization prior to occurrence of
vip and even acute renal replacement
and then there are the overall risk
factors for specific bacteria
and it's quite frequently you linked to
uh to previous uh
use which was given in many of the coded
patients
notably uh when we look at
uh healthcare associated pneumonia
in a core with 19 patients
this is a meta-analysis of 30 studies
with almost
4 000 patients and we can see that the
pooled proportion with laboratory
confirmed bacterial co-infections was
around 7
and in icu patients only it was around
14
um and in that same study when they
looked at bacterial pathogens
what is a bit surprising in this finding
is that
microplasma pneumonia was very common
other than that we are finding
the expected pathogens that we normally
see
in patients with healthcare associated
pneumonia so the reason why
microplasma was very common here is a
bit more difficult to understand but
that has not been seen in our material
for instance
and we would also not report
enterococcus
as a pathogen there are some studies
comparing culture and the impact of
molecular diagnostics in critical
illness
which were done earlier during
20 2021 and also 2020
so these are two uh published papers um
that have looked into respiratory
samples from
icu patients and found good
sensitivities and specificities
of molecular tests in this particular
case and also with the molecular tests
driving antibiotic changes
and on the other side uh the the study
um in critical care 2020
uh where uh antibiotic modifications
were also done
and illustrating the possibility of
doing
the escalation and also again
reiterating that staph aureus hemophilus
influenza and even marxella catarrhalis
were leading pathogens
detected now let's move to the material
from karolinska this is a very recent
publication in which we
applied the univero hospital acquired
pneumonia panel
on a three samples from 68 subjects
tested
using the hpn application 55 samples
were from the same number of unique
subjects
and then we had multiple samples from a
subset
of the the patients the mean age of our
patients was
slightly below the 60 and
um 74 of the samples were from males
and quantitative culture was used as a
reference in
this investigation the universe panel
looks briefly like outlined here uh
covering uh all of the pathogens we have
recently looked at in previous slides
and also a typical ones
like legionella and
and microplasma for instance it covers
also pneumocystis for instance
and um definitely also
some of the early hospital acquired
pneumonia pathogens that are more
resembling
what you find in community infections
there is also a broad array of
antibiotic resistance markers a
quite comprehensive panel for the most
common carbophenomenasis both in
enterobacteralis
and in async the bacter there is also
the ctxm for anthrobacteralis encoding
a keflosporin resistance and then some
other
um resistance scenes where maybe the
most important
is that for medicine resistance of
aureus
there is both mech a and max c
looking more into the results on the
this
investigation this is the the panel of
our findings so uh
uh stephorius was the most common uh
with
uh 23 which were regarded
through positives and also eight
that could be seen as false positives
at least if you go by culture to be
an absolute reference and to say that
culture negativity means that it should
be regarded as a false positive
but we will discuss that a little bit we
can also see
in a decreasing number of currents here
that e coli was fairly common also
and was not missed by culture in any of
them
the overall sensitivity was 95 percent
and specificity of 98 with the positive
predicted value
of around 72 and a negative predictive
value which is also very important
almost at 100
if we look further into the results
we can here study the number of samples
with concordant results
and discordant results so
that could be either standard of care
positive and the hpn
positive or standard care negative and
hpn
negative and then we can see for the
discordant results
that we had a few cases
where we found
negative with hpn and positive for
standard of care or um
there were the other way around
where we had standard of care which was
negative and hpn positive
and then sometimes they were not exactly
identifying
the the same microorganisms but those
were very few
uh occasions so here one track kill
secretion
which had grew eclepsial erogenous and
was negative by hpn and then there was
one which had
capsule erogenous and had steph auris by
hpn and there was one bal sample that
grew stepharius and klebsielle oxitoca
and for hpn we found only steph aureus
but mostly
we found more pathogens with
the hpn applications than we did with
culture
and that comes back to the definition
and sometimes when you are investigating
and comparing to standard which is less
sensitive that might lead to some
confusion
on what you should actually call false
positive
i will show you some examples of that so
this is also some overview
of the additional microorganisms
detected
with univero in eight cases uh staph
aureus
in four cases serratia in four cases
pseudomonas two cases of hemophilus
influenzae
two cases of capsule oxytoca and one
case
of uh stereotrophomonas meltophilia
which is also included in the panel
and it's obviously important to detect
because
it is intrinsically resistant against so
many
of the regular treatment alternatives
so this is an overview of the first uh
study that we conducted with a
head-to-head comparison between
the hpn application and culture
and if we look more into the subset of
patients where we did chart reviews
and had repeated samples we could
overall group them
in one group where standard care and the
hpn
was 100 concordant and then we had
another group
where the hpn pathogen was confirmed
later by standard of care in subsequent
samples
the this group of patients where
as the consequence of lack of finding
any microbial etiology they were exposed
to longer periods of
empirical treatment which could
obviously have
potential disadvantages such as
either no coverage of the pathogen or
in case it's too broad for too long uh
microbiome damage
which can also lead to other problems
such as
seed difficile infections but even
in general being highly disadvantageous
as has been shown in many
studies highlighting the importance of
the microbiome
we can also see here that the hospital
length of stay was longer in group 2
and the icu stay was longer and the vip
duration was longer we do not know if
that could have been
shorter had we had target therapy
earlier but that is at least one
possibility
that we can draw that potential
conclusion from the data set
so if we look more into universe
potential impact
more specifically and this is
where we could look at the timeline
where the univarial result could have
been available on the same day
now it was run in batches at the end of
things
so the the results were not available to
the clinician
at the time of clinical management but
we see here in group 1
and group 2 that there is quite some
difference
in how many days are elapsing before the
culture result
is available and in group 1
there is the possibility of having
pathogens not covered by empiric therapy
due to for instance intrinsic resistance
or multi-drug resistant organisms
and that could be done significantly
faster
with a molecular test like univero
and in group two where we even had
a negative culture after several days
we can say that the impact
could be even greater of having the
molecular tests
and we will look at some specific cases
at the end of this
to illustrate this maybe
a bit better the first patient case a 59
year old
where we had a tracheal aspirate which
was the most common
sample type we had this was a lady with
asthma diabetes mellitus and obesity
and um the date of covet positivity was
the 19th
of of april and then she was
put on ventilation uh in
on the 22nd of april and that continued
until the 15th of june so you see
55 days and this is the thing with the
covet patients that they are sometimes
really ventilated for
extremely long periods and particularly
this was true
at the beginning before we knew exactly
how to treat
these patients optimally unfortunately
there was a fatal
outcome for this specific patient
what we can see is that uh for the first
sampling which was done on the 20th of
may
there was pseudomonas detected
which was resistant to the treatment
which had been given prior to sampling
and the hpn application found the same
thing
whereas uh on the 30th of may
the patients was started
on capital saint peter and kalistin
prior to sampling
and we can clearly see illustrated here
that the quantitative culture becomes
then false negative whereas the hpn
application
is positive and that is corroborated
by the fact that we could later on um
recover pseudomonas in the culture from
8th of june uh so that
essentially tells the property that this
test has
to correctly identify pathogens in those
that have been previously exposed
to antimicrobials in case number two 51
year old male
this is a bal sample the first date of
covet positivity was 15th
of april um 2020
and the patient was ventilated for 53
days
and was later on discharged to to rehab
and we can see here that initially the
patient had
antibiotic microbials prior to sample
and
the quantitative culture showed yeast
whereas the hpn application showed staph
aureus
and then later on um steph aureus could
be
detected also by quantitative culture
suggesting that it was most probably
false
negative some um one week
earlier uh when it had been taken um
under
antimicrobial pressure and so the
uh this is another example of the
potential utility
and finally there is also a third case
with the 40 year old
male uh also with several comorbidities
ventilated for 46 days
and in this case we found initially
a concordant result with quantitative
culture and hpn
and then on cephotexin therapy culture
showed only serratia whereas the hpn
showed
serratia and staphorius
and staphorius was evident
later in quantitative culture which
again suggests
that these additional findings are
probably true findings
and not false positives
finally there is also some evidence that
universe system this is not from our own
investigation but from
a poster that has been shown previously
with comparison of culture
versus univero on prospective
bal samples uh also a chart review
and and with uh four culture
negativities that subsequently grew as a
vector
in culture and in this case uh the
the modification of treatment was too
late
and all the patients died i would then
in summary like to um emphasize
that distinguishing those patients with
bacterial super infections
early and accurately is highly important
for patient management
and antibiotic stewardship also that
univero demonstrated high
diagnostic yield higher than culture
enabling
a more rapid diagnosis in hospitalized
core with
patients or at least would have done had
the result been available
an excellent negative predictive value a
strongly reduced diagnostic turnaround
time
and also that many uh that were culture
negative initially were positive in
subsequent cultures
uh and as a conclusion uh univero could
provide clinicians with earlier data
to inform and microbial decisions and
with that
i would like to thank you for your
attention
and i would like to leave the words
to dr bell for the second talk thank you
very much
okay thank you dr jiska
get control here all right so um i'm
drew bell
i'm the uh micro fellow at iu as i was
mentioned earlier
um as uh part of my fellowship i've
gotten involved
in our group's industry-sponsored
research group
and today i'm going to talk to you a
little bit about a study that we
performed in conjunction with option
testing out the universe seeing how it
performed in
some subsets of our patients
after we kind of talked about the study
i'll go through some specific cases as
well that i think exemplify
the um the characteristics of molecular
testing in this type of
diagnostic algorithm
so we've talked a little bit about
pneumonia of course there's
serious clinical implications when it
comes to pneumonia
it's relatively common it kind of
plagues our hospital systems
and it comes with significant costs
increased lengths of hospital stay
are going to increase of course the the
chances for
patients to have adverse outcomes and
also
you know the amount of money that it
takes in the capacity of the hospital
um we're also going to see changes uh
our significant uh
contributions to mortality
when you look at hospital acquired and
ventilator associated pneumonia
together they're a very common form of
possible acquire infections we're
very concerned about controlling them in
our hospital system
and of course with these infections
we're really worried about resistance
either they're picking up the organism
from the hospital itself where
you know we're going to see more
resistant pathogens but then also within
the treatment of each patient we have to
be sure that we're using
our antimicrobials wisely and we don't
want to accidentally begin to develop
antimicrobial resistance of course on
the right here we have
some of the pathogens we've talked about
is more of our common
acute pneumonia causers and hospitalized
patients and of course many of these uh
are associated with some particular
mechanisms of resistance
so we're really concerned about the
types of
antimicrobials that we're using in these
patients
so kind of key to our therapy
is an ideologic diagnosis
so conventionally these ideological
diagnoses of pneumonia are going to rely
on
more microscopic observations you know
looking at a gram stain seeing if we see
any bacteria or not
and then following up with culture um
the sensitivity isn't great for these
types of tests and it does take
a significant amount of time you know if
you're waiting for culture you're
waiting at least
you know 16 to 24 hours before you
actually have the organism there
therefore your traditional therapies are
going to be empiric you're kind of
starting a broad
antibiotic therapy while you're figuring
out what pathogens are present and
how could you possibly narrow that
therapy or making sure that you're
including drugs to cover resistance you
want to see so really these
tiny timely escalations and
de-escalations are going to need some
input from the lab we're going to need
some laboratory information
uh the figure here uh is from a study
that was kind of looking at
uh the importance of initial appropriate
or appropriate initial therapy
in the patient's clinical course of
course this is
in community acquired pneumonia and
really what we see is that if you have
appropriate initial therapy your
hospital stays are lower
and your readmission rate is also lower
um interestingly this particular study
did not find that uh there was a
difference in mortality but
you're in decreasing the amount of time
spent in the hospital and you're
preventing those patients from coming
back which is always a good thing
so when kind of thinking of these
conventional
conditions there are some strengths that
molecular culture or molecular
diagnostics can provide
so we can reduce that time to
appropriate therapy if we can
figure out the organism or we can figure
out the resistance pattern
earlier on this is not only good to get
the patients out of the hospital but
if you have antibiotic stewardship
initiatives in place
it's going to help you be more judicious
with your prescriptions
and then of course the resistance that
we talked about we'll talk a little bit
about uh
pneumocystis pneumonia in a moment but
that type of diagnosis is
fairly insensitive actually and so this
provides a notable improvement
to that as well um there are also some
challenges
when it comes to molecular diagnosis
more
just sort of cultural adjustments in how
we interpret this type of data
so it's going to be much more sensitive
you know very very tiny amounts of dna
uh it could be amplified now this
is mostly a good thing in the sense that
we'll know all the
pathogens that are there or perhaps
something being treated uh
the patient has already started therapy
you might still find out if that
organism is present
present or not um so we just have to
know that we're going to
be able to see things a lot clearer
at the same time we have to keep in mind
that you know ordering these
tests we have to think about the costs
associated with them so there
um are a few costs that we think about
on the laboratory side one of course is
the cost of the test itself
so molecular uh diagnostic panels uh
can be kind of expensive and so we have
to keep in mind that
if we don't need the broad panel then we
should stick to
focus diagnostics but there are times
when we don't really know and we have to
think about
different pathogens and that's where the
panel has a place we also have to think
about
the cost of the the instruments and
implementing these instruments
themselves
um for us that really means that we want
to find a platform that
kind of meets our needs as a laboratory
so
do we have the organisms that we're most
concerned about you know can we use this
as a replacement
or maybe not a replacement but an
adjunct to culture for particular
uh complicated organisms which we'll
mention
um and then we also want to keep in mind
that although it kind of gives a preview
of resistance
looking for the presence of markers or
not really we have to
uh keep in mind that we only have a good
basis for escalation
in the sense that if we see a resistant
marker we can have a good idea if it's
resistant
but if we don't see the resistance
marker we have to be cautious about how
we de-escalate because susceptibility
can still
go away in a sense with the phenotypic
testing so just we've talked about it
briefly uh
before but we'll touch on again uh so
the technology we're looking at is the
univaro lrt bal
um this is uh for our viewers across the
pond this is equivalent to the
hpn panel uh used in the previous talk
um one one of the reasons that our lab
was
uh interested in testing this out is it
does include some sort of fastidious
or difficult to culture or completely
unculturable organisms
so you have your mycoplasma your
chlamydia
your legionella and your pneumocystis
and of course the the small amount of
hands on time is
a big benefit too so just so we're on
the same page about uh
pjp or pneumocystis eurovici pneumonia
this is one of the non-culturable fungi
it is
uh fairly prevalent in immunocompromised
patients
especially hiv infected patients or who
we
think of the most but also you know
anybody else who has
immune suppression
we see somewhat different courses
in folks with hiv than with those who do
not have hiv
and so that will kind of change um
our understanding of hiv negative
pneumocystis will probably change
as we gain more molecular information
we also want to be cautious of the
treatment for pjp
and that uh tremendous trimethoprim
sulfamethoxazole or bacterium or
sxt is associated with some adverse
effects so we
really want to be careful with this drug
um we should note that there is some
amount of colonization
that can occur in the population so
we're really just starting to learn
about this as we employ molecular
technologies
so there is some colonization in you
know competent individuals
and we're starting to think that maybe
this organism is playing a role
in some conditions that
were previously ignored because they
were unable to be identified
microscopically so an immunocompetent
individual's of burden is usually a bit
lower
and in that sense we might be able to
detect more with
uh molecular technology we see some
co-infection
of course in the high-risk populations
and you'll notice that some of the risk
factors for genesis colonization really
overlap with the risk factors for
uh pneumocystis pneumonia themselves so
sometimes
colonization is thought maybe more of a
threshold that we cross
than anything else
when we're conventionally diagnosing pjp
what we're really uh looking at is
uh the trophic or cystic forms
uh that we see in microscopic
examination um
carrying out these uh stains and looking
at them under the scope is kind of a
pain
and the sensitivity just isn't great
especially when burdens are low
as in as they are in immunocompetent
individuals
um and there's lots of great evidence of
course that uh
real-time pcr is good for detection and
is especially good for ruling out
pneumocystis
the negative predictive value is
extraordinarily high
so in this particular study uh we wanted
to compare
uh our uh standard of care uh
identification scheme so that's mostly
we're just gonna be talking about
bacteria and then of course
pneumocystis here uh and then we wanted
to compare them with the molecular
technology that the universe
provides so really we're seeing is that
uh
we're going to collect a bal um usually
we can get an id
uh in between 16 and 24 hours but it
could be longer if it's a tricky
organism or a slow grower
and then at the very earliest we can get
susceptibility testing at 24 hours
these base numbers here are if
everything goes right
on our standard of care and everything
lines up with when
uh we can carry out those tests and
everything everything is behaving not
always the case but they're
good starting numbers and of course um
for patients with concern with pjp we
really are going to be looking
microscopically so
this was a number of stains including
some that aren't exactly relevant to pjp
diagnosis
but we're getting generally can we see
anything
okay including the study we had 63
individuals mostly male
in fairly wide age range although they
tended to be older
we had a nice mix of community acquired
hospital acquired
and ventilator so associated pneumonia
and then a
few patients with no pneumonia
whatsoever
also including this number are nine
patients that were determined to have
pneumocystis pneumonia by our standard
of care diagnostic album
so when we compared our
universal results to our standard of
care
we saw a pretty good agreement but i
should mention the types of disagreement
that we could see
just so we're all on the same page here
really when you compare two methods you
um
are your new method can either add
a new organism or it can forget an
organism you know omit one
when it comes to our cutoffs here i i
kind of categorize them into two bins
being uh either minor editions
or uh major uh are minor omissions and
then
major additions and major emissions here
um the way that we quantify our cultures
is important so you know if we see
1 000 colonies that may only be
sorry 1 000 cfu per ml there may only be
actually one colony on a plate so
not many colonies whatsoever we also
quantify by quadrant of growth so being
1 plus 2 plus 3 plus
1 plus being very relatively little
growth here
so when we did uh make this comparison
though we did see a large amount of
complete agreement about 75 which is
uh pretty good and kind of in line with
what other studies have seen as well
we also saw a few cases where there were
some minor emissions
uh and minor editions uh and then some
uh major uh missions and major additions
uh we'll talk about a few of these uh
cases of the major cases and there may
be more to them than
just uh do they agree or do they not
agree
um in fact because of the increased
performance of molecular assays
we also looked at the treatments that
these patients received so
kind of discounting the molecular data
for a second
and this is what we would have done with
those patients have we had
perfect diagnostic technology and could
see the future
and what we saw is a lot of patients
were under treated
and you know a significant amount were
over treated and some were just fine
only about a quarter were
on the right treatment to begin with um
and then of course
some of these especially the patients
without pneumonia at all were
considered to be appropriate without any
treatment whatsoever
and so when we kind of factored in our
univera results here
we saw that we could change the way that
some of these therapies would have gone
so about 40 of cases the results would
have
prompted either an escalation or a
de-escalation of therapy
there again were some where the
treatment was not needed at all so
we we would not factor in that analysis
here when we talk about not enough
information
about a third of these cases it was
either not enough information
that we could find in the chart or there
was just not enough new information
provided by the universe in the sense
that
it kind of supported the current therapy
as well
but a good amount of escalation so when
we think about those patients who are
being under-treated
this provided good evidence to put them
on maybe some stronger drugs
or more targeted drugs
okay so we'll go through some cases
and then we'll wrap up and have time for
questions so this first case we have
is a 50 year old guy who uh had a
uh history of acute myeloid leukemia and
was
uh received a stem cell transplant for
that and he comes in with a
fever a cough and some shortness of
breath
he had influenza infection recently
and had been kind of in and out of uh
hospital for treatment for that
and they were giving him tamiflu
oxifloxacin is a prophylactic
his symptoms weren't improving and uh
when the patient came back in they they
placed them on vancomycin and cepapine
[Music]
but after a week they discontinued this
uh
vancomycin as bals and cultures
repeatedly showed only uh influenza so
they thought they were clear of the
bacterial woods
in this particular case our standard of
care culture
identified staff aureus
[Music]
and uh at about 16 hours and then the
only scan
eight hours later um uh identified that
there was methicillin resistance
at this point about a day after uh
stopping the therapy
they restarted back on vancomycin
this is one of those cases where the
universo would have come up with a bit
faster of an answer
so it detected the staph aureus early at
its five-hour time point but it also had
the mecca marker there so we could
know that uh the
vancomycin therapy would have been
appropriate at this five hour mark
so this would have been a good 11 to 18
hours earlier than
with our conventional diagnostics
this is a good example um why i chose
included was
that really this is a why we like
molecular technologies they provide a
prompt
basis for escalation uh this is also a
case where the standard of care was
performing very well
in the sense that everything was done
within that 24-hour period it can take
much longer
to get these final reports
but this one we had early identification
on the standard of care side as well
but it would have been much earlier if
we had our molecular technology in place
the second case we have an older woman
coming in
she has a history of copd chronic kidney
disease
some tobacco abuse and she has
shortness of breath cough wheezing
weakness and is feeling kind of strange
when they did a ct they noticed that
there was a
right cavitary lesion and for which they
wanted to get some fluid
and so they sent bal in for culture
while they're waiting for the results
they started on this patient on pip taso
and is with termicin
so in this case we detected the
m-cataralles at about 24 hours so
still pretty good as far as our
identification pipeline and then we
confirmed that it was pan susceptible
at 48 hours the following day
so following identification we reduced
the treatment just to tiptaso here
which we'll talk about in a second how
we feel about that
so here the univera would have also
identified the uh more excel cataracts
wouldn't have had any resistance markers
in about five hours so we've got an
earlier answer here
um so really
when we think about how we treat this
talking to our infectious disease
pharmacy team
um they thought that this was a bit
overkill
um and although we were able to drop the
uh
the zithromycin and just go with the pip
tazo
they felt that they we could have gone
even further and perhaps reduced this to
something like
a mox collab so this is a case where
these type this type of information can
inform antibiotic stewardship
initiatives
and maybe help de-escalate when possible
so we think of this as giving early
basis for us to de-escalate therapy
fortunately in this particular case uh
there was never another pathogenic
organism uh recovered but
the patient continued to have a chronic
hypoxic and hyper
carbic respiratory failure and the
kidney disease
uh became worse um
was eventually discharged to hospice
so this third case is a
younger guy uh and he has no significant
medical history
he's coming in with some dry coughs on
his breath and some uh subjective fever
and chills
uh they found he had a low two sets and
they took
uh a ct of lungs where they saw a ground
glass passes
they also noticed oral thrush on a
physical exam
which uh they started treating the
fluconazole and kind of made the
decisions in this case
worry about hiv although the
the patient denied any risk factors um
so despite a nice broad antibiotic
coverage
the patient did not get better
so when they did do the scandal care uh
uh bal uh culture and micro microscopic
analysis
they uh noticed that there was uh
pneumocystis uh
this occurred really quickly at about
six and a half hours after collection
um and right about the time that this
new assistant's result came back the
antibody results
also came back positive so this patient
was started uh immediately on bacterium
about six and a half hours so this is
kind of a classic
diagnosis of when things go right for
pneumocystis
diagnostics in this case the univera
would have been
a little bit faster than this at about
five hours
kind of the main benefit that we see in
this particular case
is uh getting all those slides and
reading them uh
requires uh advanced uh technical skills
it also is
a significant amount of labor the
universe is pretty straightforward and
uh
only requires a couple minutes to set
things up and so we kind of see it as
expanding the ability to perform this
type of testing without
necessarily having the expertise or the
extra hands-on time
in case four there's a little bit of a
challenge case for the
the for the individual here um we have a
fourth year old woman
comes with fatigue weight loss anorexia
over four months
recently having shortness of breath and
some other respiratory symptoms
the ct demonstrated a mass like opacity
with multiple nodules and ground glass
opacities
and uh they were concerned about hiv
based off of a couple of
risk behaviors and
uh came back with a very low or of
course came back positive and the cd
count
the cd4 count was very low uh so
immediately they're looking at the bal
to
see if they can come up with a an agent
for some of these respiratory systems
so our standard of care procedure only
identified staph aureus uh and some
normal for some non-cryptococcus feasts
and
uh uh other organisms um this patient
was started on pip tazo uh to treat the
uh uh susceptible snap forest i should
mention that it came back susceptible
and was also prophylactically treated
just
by having uh hiv with cd4 count so low
presumably for a long time as well so
treated
both for adm and for
pjp prophylaxis so
the univariate however did identify
pneumocystis at about five hours
and also picked up a staph aureus so
in this case we're kind of thinking that
maybe we're seeing
a higher sensitivity here that this
patient
pneumocystis would have been a good
hypothesis as to why she was
feeling ill in this case they're already
prophylactically treating it
without any necessary laboratory
evidence so
it's hard to tell this this counted as a
disagreement a major disagreement in the
um
uh compar comparative analysis we're
thinking that maybe we're actually
detecting
something that microscopy just couldn't
and really providing a basis for some of
the therapies that we've already been
starting empirically
and prophylactically that maybe we can
now identify them
from a molecular standpoint
okay uh here's our last case um so we
have
a 53 year old guy who recently
had a bilateral lung transplant and he's
presenting with some
uh not very fun respiratory symptoms
uh while he was recovering from his uh
lung transplants
uh he kept having some pseudomonas uh
tranquil uh bronchitis uh infection
uh which turned out to be carbon
sensitive every time that it came
up this was now several weeks ago and
thoughts have been uh resolved the
patient had been uh
treated with uh inhaled cliffs and they
kind of thought that they were over this
uh so they sent in this bronchoscopy
with a a
bale and looking to culture it see what
would grow at this point our standard of
care was able to identify a pseudomonas
at 24 hours
at this point in time they started
treating them as if it were the original
isolate
so using those uh carbopen sensitive
uh characteristics um
but then unfortunately carbopenemys our
carbopenem not carbohydrate resistance
was reported the next day so
here the universe was uh able to detect
the pseudomonas aerogenosa at five hours
very quickly
but didn't detect any resistance markers
so this is kind of another tricky case
where
the universe came in and was able to get
us a pathogenic identification much
earlier
so we would have known that pseudomonas
was back um
but one of the tricky things with
organisms like pseudomonas of course is
that the lack of a resistance marker
doesn't necessarily mean
that there will be no resistance and
for this we still need phenotypic
follow-up but in this particular case at
least we have sort of a day's head start
we know that the organism is there and
we can kind of
treat aggressively knowing that it's
very possible that
you can have resistance without the
marker here
okay so just kind of in conclusion for
this study what we found we think that
really there's a lot of opportunity for
implementing these rapid molecular
diagnostic
tests into uh respiratory algorithms um
of course
there's no substitute for phenotypic
antimicrobial susceptibility testing but
just by having
answers up to a day or more earlier
um you can get faster identify
identification of these pathogens
especially the well-known uh resistance
mechanisms we can have an idea of
what drugs to escalate to to begin with
um it also can reduce the time that we
can use to
increase therapy or decrease therapy
kind of rain back some
overzealous uh prescriptions and know
when it's
really needed to include tougher drugs
um also compared to some of the uh
technologies either culture
or microscopy we think that there's
improved sensitivity
and this for us is quite a benefit
okay and with that uh i think we're done
so we'll turn it over to questions
thank you dr jeske and dr bell for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is for dr jeske of the cases that you
presented
by how many days faster or earlier
did univero detect a pathogen that
culture confirmed in a subsequent
sample yes thank you very much for that
question
i think in general the answer is
three to seven days earlier
with univero in some cases
where the results were 100
concordant it was slightly
shorter than that but still
at least two days earlier
great thank you so much and dr bell
we'll go ahead and scooch on over to you
so the question for you is what is your
experience
regarding universe detection of p
eurovici
uh being pathogenic or due to
colonization
oh that that's a great question so we we
kind of talked a little bit about how
there is colonization at play but um i
didn't specifically address how
this molecular technology was did have
that in mind when it was developed
so in general when we think about the
burden of pneumocystis
studies have found that probably the the
cut off for
being pneumonia causing versus just a
colonizer is about 10 to the fifth
copies per ml so if it's below that it
might just be a colonizer but if it's
above that it's it's
likely to be playing a role on pneumonia
and so uh
the the nice thing about the universe
here is that it actually the analytical
sensitivity was
set to uh 10 to the fifth copies per
mill
to hopefully just pick up those cases
which are true now you know
there's always a little bit of wiggle
room and things like this so there might
be some edge cases
uh but uh we think that it's pretty in
line with
what we know about pjp colonization at
this time
wonderful thank you so much dr bell and
so
it looks like we have time for just
about one more question but i do want to
remind our audience that any questions
that we are unable to answer today
and those that come in during the on
demand period will be answered by our
speakers via the email address that you
provided
at the time of registration so please
don't hesitate to keep those questions
coming in
um so dr jeske we'll go ahead and end
with you
um with this question some pcr pneumonia
panels have semi-quantitative reporting
capability
so what is your opinion about this
this is a very typical
discussion i think in general it depends
also largely on the sensitivity
of the pcr and the level of detection of
the pcr
and it seems at least in the patient
material that we investigated
there was a very good concordance
between
pcr and and quantitative culture
at the significance levels that
are considered significant so
despite that one could fear that
pcr would pick up very small amounts
it does seem as if the kit
without knowing specifically is fairly
adapted
to the levels that you would typically
regard as
significant in culture so i think
in this data set we looked at
it would not have made a huge difference
um but it depends if
it's an extremely sensitive pcr it might
make more difference
great thank you so much dr jeske we want
to thank you
think again dr jeske and dr bell um
do you have any final comments for our
audience for excuse me for our audience
um dr jeske i'll go ahead and
begin with you
no just that i would like to say um
we will definitely try to answer
questions from
from the chat and whatever we were not
able to
to address for time constraints here uh
so i'm more than willing to discuss more
uh with anyone who might be interested
after this
seminar and thanks to all who attended
thank you and dr bell do you have any
final closing comments for us
just similar thank you all for attending
and please reach out if you have any
questions we didn't get to we'll try to
get to them all so thank you
great thank you both before we go i
would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
like we mentioned questions that we do
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
jeske and dr bell for their time today
and their important research
we would also like to thank labrets and
our sponsor opt-gen
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
laberts will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
that's all for now
thank you for joining us stay happy stay
safe stay healthy
until next time bye bye everyone thank
you